I know this is going to sound like crazy
animal lady I realized I had such
self-esteem stuff I didn't have a dog I
didn't have something that was just
giving me unconditional love that really
helped me I had some intimacy stuff and
I realized a lot of my toughness had to
do with being scared of intimacy being
loved rejected animals really help me
with that because it gives you a little
bit of data no matter how much of a
piece of I might think I am and how
much I fear that the world thinks I am
my dog still loves I'm doing pretty good
yeah this thing that I think is cool
he's alive he seems to be happy that I'm
here we waste a lot of time trying to as
we say in program don't try to meet
internal needs with external things I
was never a as an alcohol person but I
was definitely a people person if I just
have this many friends if this guy is
attracted to me maybe that means that
I'm not totally nothing but like having
a lot of emotional needs met from
animals really did I think keep me out
of a lot of trouble when you're in your
20s like how do you get your emotional
needs met so you're not wasting time and
hurting other people and hurting
yourself being in relationships you
shouldn't be in by fostering dogs I kind
of accidentally hacked that